all right welcome to another Friday
edition first Friday of the year play
the people starring Mike comer alongside
Jonathan Krantz yeah looking forward to
it so this is where you got a whole new
set up here if you are looking for us we
got all the cameras we got the TriCaster
we got o miked up so please let us know
if you can hear us there's no there's
any issues here with I think we can't
hear because I think you have your audio
on ok so the other thing very
disappointing and yeah and if so in a
few minutes it'll pop up on my chest
some people see it and then they'll
start challenging us you've got to get
preferred time control we are we are
playing a game one minute one oh rated
so don't send me any other challenges
all right unless you want to play
Jonathan cuz he might sub in for me yeah
whoever every now and then because we
are actually at work so who knows what
we might have to actually go do but yeah
weird way so why you're waiting to
people are saying hey Mike so do devils
and yeah I guess if you're right I mean
if you just want to play a game to get
the people warmed up you know change
that to one Oh give it a go well yeah do
challenge us our name is st. Louis just
Club unless
well no whoa no whoa no whoa no create
the occasional Oh big blunder calibrate
it to I separated you know not Horde oh
my gosh whatever that means don't do it
all right for you no don't do horde
that's not for you
what opal there you all right very ready
I got my Red Bull I'll be ready to roll
all right are you sponsored not yet but
I'm always taken I'm always taken up
barri down upon not a good place to be
fun that's fine
Jonathan says it's fine it's fine yeah
you're my comer so you find get my King
side attack going
this guy is killing me this guy must
have been GM Maurice T Ashley in the
crowd saying he can hear us loud and
clear that's good to know
actually hear us that's good we're up to
a whopping 15 viewers it makes me feel
like perhaps we're not oh it does say
now on my chest I bet in a minute or two
here
alright dodge these know what up there
and all right good to see you Monster
Hunter unite all I got to do is give
this guy some kind of check and I'll be
the victor and then yeah hopefully this
is something we can do regularly on
Fridays with my comer at this time all
right got his bishop got his double
pawns got my queen in there let's just
hurry up here okay yeah
that's another problem which maybe we
need Mouse baths
yep we didn't really think this one
through too well try throwing around go
offense don't have to own it check I'm
just gonna take a draw I think if he
wants draw he doesn't want to draw good
he had his chance he had his chance
don't tell me you didn't have this
chance Oh coming over oh I can't look at
your 7 K says I can't read
oh now this guy's trying to checkmate me
that's not so funny up the game's over
someone's gonna somebody flag somebody
you're faster than everybody up not
without my Brooke fast by the old
stalemate trick huh
Oh bye stalemate is what we are going
for right now just for the record
Oh IIIi did a chest all pre moves it's
the only way he got all right so now I'm
not a good not a good start for Michel
commerce oh I am vulnerable it looks
like very very vulnerable I'm just gonna
wait for that the caffeine to sink in
once that hits we should be good to go
here that's one challenge who are you
does it make I said check out my stream
buddy get the challenge thing challenge
god the swords all right we got one
challenge is one o Muhammad I think I
played him before all right let's go
remember the results he probably beat me
I lose a lot he'll lose oh yeah I pinned
his Knight he probably doesn't know I
did something I think it's something I
did something I think could come down
and check me all right but there's a
major problem here we only got like 30
people
what's going on well the way I'm playing
that's all I desert right
people will come when you start playing
better is Yasser as nice in real life as
he is on stream he is absolutely the
nicest guy in real life amen
yeah yeah well you see what you see on
the stream is who he also really is
I am a big big trouble me it's one
minute so being in trouble doesn't
matter as much
you can survive being in trouble not in
this position oh I got a little I got a
little Oh No all right Dan I need on
mouse patters yeah yeah this is bad okay
you need to chug it I think that's the
only way good okay all right so tough
one more challenges we do have a chance
after that one they were like okay I can
beat this guy no problem at all Zach
that I think this is the guy I need he's
gonna be the one that oh yeah you're
getting good check him out yeah you can
beat him
yeah no mouse pad means no victories
just play better oh all right all right
thank you I guess this guy's feels bad
I'll take some pity victories why not
I look good I know Anna though I got the
biggest mouse pad in the land Wow
it has a mouse on it that's awesome
hopefully they can see that on the
street
yeah all right see how much better I'm
playing now that it's got all to do with
the mouse pad please play your Bishop
onna so I can just take your stuff
yeah I know out there and checkmate here
all right all right here we go here we
go here we go
yeah this guy yeah he's nothing without
his must by finally all thanks for the
game Mohamed he says gg all right
but yeah line up now there's not a whole
lot of people waiting in the queue so
yeah line up now you'll get to play mic
challenge him to one oh I don't think
that zach is good but who cares right
yeah exa PC just checkmates you a
hundred percent Wow what's the plan
Bishop check all right up there
checkmate home come on that's the plan
that's where I got another eye in that
it's not cool for you Jonathan
hey it's pretty Cosmo is eight good to
see you Rajesh all right and I can go
fast almost ooh what I challenge you you
sure can if you go find st. Louis chess
club on me chess you can challenge us so
challenge Mike to a one-minute game so
every Friday it's gonna be Mike show i'm
well i don't i think i might get
cancelled after the people love you oh
[Music]
no no pity win enough
oh so close I only did it what yeah yeah
you're really mocking you
wailing mocking me oh well done good
game man bye mr. blitz all right do you
need another is that maybe where's Perry
with the coffee come on now
now I do have my set up just right so I
have no excuses and I got two challenges
whoever's Oh
dealer ooh thank God standard yeah sure
yeah oh yeah
this appears to be Dennis people may
have seen on this stream before this is
our club so I'll take one exception for
two minutes just for him because I got
to get on the board today I got think he
lost wondering it's fun to just take it
just take it
he loves blundering is fun I always take
it so I I've read a write monster saying
this is a great idea you've got all the
fancy broadcasting gear and cool chess
people it's awesome and we'll see more
of you
also good to see you too comment monster
this is all mr. abend Feingold it's
called the Ben fangled defense he's an
advocate but it doesn't matter there's a
book with his name on it yeah I play
this so great I can't even talk about it
yeah I mean you shouldn't all these
secrets or whatever if you don't let
anyone know the thing with two minutes
and I am playing Dennis LaRue he could
be using a chess engine he doesn't seem
like the type
and I just blundered upon unbelievable
on anyway so now it's equal that's fine
but little does he know I didn't I did
yeah yeah Knight b6 he'll never see it
time to go get the coffee thank you
thank goodness alright
yeah so it's I don't know which camera
it is I guess that's really the sky I
don't know I can wave oh I see myself
live I won't have to wait forever to see
so Knight b6 an idea cuz he can just
drop oh my no can't have four texts in
like one second I need it I need it
yeah you should show that to the people
cuz it's what am I done here
alright can you guys still hear me - I
mess up my mic seems likely yeah sure
get what you need what do you need Mike
a double shot espresso and one of those
of batali cans and write it down get a
phone get your notes I got text you
there's important stuff here I'm going
to beat my comer says Eddie Adi Chandra
yeah hopefully
howdy Chandra has never beaten me in his
life true stories name anyone
one two three let's just not get back
row checkmate it and I think I can win
this game Oh we'll do what do you want I
want just coffee John Day and Mike you
want a double shot of espresso correct
right double shot espresso hot it's just
a little cup hot yes yes a black cherry
if they got it if not refreshers yeah
strawberry whatever doesn't matter yeah
yeah the two of us combined a 4-1 Grand
Master that's cool here
come on checkmate come on second mate I
do a 1k I kicking hope right a kick and
hope one just may both sides of bound
yeah what do you expect what do you
expect did you crush this guy yet
just please how is he up on time on you
he's the slowest player I've ever seen I
don't know can i pre move of course you
can take it when you're King and they're
really fast go run I know what is with
this pre move device
yes we're gonna yeah it's an easy flag
easy flag
that's pretty voice doesn't work this is
perfect this is good
oh my god we got the the GM title on
Leech s because every Thursday we'll
have the GM and res here playing on the
stream so yeah all the time we'll have a
lots of lots of GM's here playing and
Wow who knows who we're gonna end up
getting especially we have some big
events and stuff so all right perfectly
played game I didn't see any blenders I
didn't either fine goal defense
victorious again easy win so shock that
one up to grandmaster been flying goal
the best coach I ever had
alright Bananarama how way is it 1o
standard I don't know I mean I just need
to read it like instead of casual its
standard like standard rated not
casually oh right Bananarama let's go to
Rama let's go let's go let's go let's go
let's go all right jugo can hear me
because I feel like I may have
dislocated the mic but people haven't
complained yet so trusting that it looks
fine
hey it's got one right chayo where
you're live on Twitter in the stream
Oh No so it's on this camp look we got
the TriCaster today see how awesome
[Laughter]
all right hey my name oh who are you
guys this is Mike comer playing Beck
this is a long one
hi guys my local chess club in Australia
is really struggling to attract new
members almost all of our members are
over 60 as a successful club how do you
attract new members to your chess club
I'll let Mike handle that one how do we
get the trick how do we get members
there's a tough one
here's a tough one I'm in a middle of
something though right now that's what
they like wrote to the screwer
well thank God thank God I need all the
help I can get all the help I can
please play rook takes night yeah I
think the secret is just having a place
people want to come so I mean it might
be slow going at first unless you have
like huge funds or something but just
kind of create an environment people
want to go to my name is Joe Jonathan I
watched all your videos that's
impressive
cuz I feel like I have a lot I don't
think I could sit and watch them all
good job buddy thank you Joe why does he
just take my rook let's go what are you
thinking about buddy way to buy valuable
time a very good strategic decision I
know all right
good plan just play fast go fast the
best that's the key there's different
ways to win in chess slow and good well
that's really hard fast and bad most
people can handle that Oh
whole team is not doing too well the
tape where's Dennis LaRue a player Josh
evil dead have you seen his name you got
always 13:31 thank you thank you thank
the route is it okay if I'm late because
I'm watching the stream Oh Ryan cuz I'm
not at the front I don't know no I mean
how can he come to work today he's
watching the stream you should be here
already watching the stream in real life
alright I got this one I got this one in
the bag of I can't win this one I might
just have to call it a day f6 all right
everybody's favorite double bond double
in the runs that's your thing I'm gonna
kiss right good game big sander vibe
must be
that's really you want [ __ ] eligible
I'm a bishop you can have it he's not
cooperating no way what's that pawn I
get much are you not challenged me on my
chess well I know we haven't got there
yet we're starting to get a couple
people in the queue we'll get around to
as many as weekend in just one minute so
that's a lot of people will get an
opportunity I'm that good friend all
right here we go here we go here we go
let's do this start crushing people
please Chuck all right it was that good
enough for you he took it yeah yeah I'm
threatening checkmate come on 1331 1331
1531 just what the doctor ordered yeah
mister 1331 and if you're under 1331
please uh all right let's play this guy
he thinks he's so good a chess expert
onli chess Wow
it's pine nick risco right hey black
hands he says my cover the legend huge
you're a legend so don't let the people
down I got castled go Mike
alright thanks for the game ROG yeah
sure thing relish anytime anytime don't
trap my bishop please don't trip you can
go back oh but I can see I got that
passport and his passport is not very
good
gonna take a lot of time trying to
defend apart but everything's changing
now things are looking up things are
looking up in the world
is it hot is it hot was that hot you're
in a lot of trouble a lot of trouble
alright yeah things are really kicking
into gear yes we gotta get ready
we got a refresher or whatever Express I
lost my pass on we are all the drinks
like another wises but that's the camera
so sorry yeah yeah the camera changed so
we got this like whole set up today
so these are the TriCaster bruising the
mics they say it's good hey Raj with 100
bits happy new year thank you I'm
playing a chess expert and he's crushing
me yeah I'd like to sit here and say
Mike's been crushing people but it
doesn't feel like the honest truth you
guys only doing bullet today yeah no
probably not
we're gonna have to switch it up today I
think we should I think if you just you
just need a little more time like today
today today today you know it's okay I
got stalemate possibilities galore keep
going faster it's okay to be down three
pieces but then you should be up on time
they should have six seconds and they're
like the opposite if you have six
seconds in you're down three pieces
that's bad it's bad everything all right
oh this is a tough day for anything hey
everyone ago the only guy I beat was uh
kind of slow rhythm one minutes but if
you're feeling like Maddie
Artie these are all by the way yeah come
on kick him when he's down kick him when
he's down people yeah yeah yeah who
doesn't need better parry I will see him
for the Friday action quad so that must
be the audience yeah ox brother Rock
Chandra's brother you guys are the only
two signed up so far so good
hey better start probably a game man
happen for you yeah that's cool so we
got a lot of local people here watching
us today yeah we're up to 69 years I
wish they were just anonymous people yes
right now it's on twitch yeah you could
go and watch the games live so I guess
you'd see it like 30 seconds before
anybody else if people are following a
significant they won't fall enough they
don't stay down there I can't
that far away - spectators - spectators
how is Arjun I even seen Arjun in
forever but I really work weekends
anymore
I did see Arjun the other he was playing
in a tournament and he was like winning
you like tied for first or something in
some tournament Arjun
that sounds like him his birthday's
coming up his birthday is in January but
our great his birthdays in February but
he celebrates that at the end of January
I guess he just can't wait for his
birthday so but yeah and that's yeah
that's his thing - it's always like he
celebrates his birthday late and teaches
patience patient interesting I think
that's why they - it needs just like
he's just happy with it
he doesn't just not because he asked you
or anything he just I think I gotta get
a check made it pretty soon yes I know
what challenge you you got challenge us
we don't know you're you're lead chess
challenges st. Louis Chess Club I'm Lee
just any reckon and recommendations for
aggressive trap openings after a 45 come
on no checkmate
come on no checkmate come on no
checkmate which side oh that was good
move
finally finally a good move little late
the never side or Lathan / faster yeah
good really bad moves faster that'll
slow them down get your books into
checking position super easy win another
crush by Mike comer all right thank you
scuba Mike in your opinion what's the
best genre of music to play chess -
definitely uh anybody heard of me first
and the Gimme Gimmes it's uh they do
punk rock covers of all the greatest
songs from Elton John to Billy Joel -
sound bad suggestion all the good ones
standard casual raided that one's rated
3 Oh though you want to play checkmate
I'm just going back to the people to the
real people they're not the father was
seeking you to challenge him as if we
know his you got a challenge oh come on
my name is st. Louis just um oh there's
even a link there now you can challenge
us yes everybody's texting right here we
go here we go here we go this thing was
predicted I don't need to castle and I
don't need a castle like weird I like
we're going back and forth I like that
little tip they almost accepted
checkmate you got to make it 100
checkmate how over fast I'm moving I'm
moving and moving and moving and moving
man this is all falling apart without
that poornam north booth without their
poles
the end of the day you're always Michael
J you got this okay just yeah like my
chances here I like my way up on time
just keep up keep up the time and keep
playing good moves yes I wanted them to
do that so bad
if only I could castle in this position
Oh Oh God yeah we're recommending the
Latvian gambit there's a interesting
gamut thank you for the game all right
thanks for the game checkmate always
trying to get a single couple oh yeah I
might I might need a sub in for Perry so
why don't you well not not now but
pretty soon pretty soon so so yeah send
a three-minute game not five minutes we
don't got time Wow and you just sack up
on make sure you open it up you're up in
development sack upon yeah I'm like
knows what's up all right how can I
challenge Mike you go to leech s org and
you challenge st. Louis chess club all
one word all spelled out s a int and
it's also a link that was posted there
in the chat so that's like a plan all
right
checkmate we might get you in here we're
messing up checkmate
we didn't take us three minutes no it's
not taking this one minute a good idea
Perry good idea good idea
you want three minute Perry I wouldn't
even play
I meant I would play I play that's what
I do on my Tuesday show oh I'm a mouse
lip Mouse lip to end the day last lip to
end the day come on Artie can you guys
show you I'm in a studio right now
can I show audio to challenge Mike yep
you know what these puns are pretty fast
these poems are pretty fast
I need I needed that other pawn no I
don't want to lose your pawn whatever
you don't want to Queen Anne they take
you because then you can't win do you
have the pawn on the board then you yeah
the last thing I'm gonna do is take that
I still can't take I guess I'm going
better than the description there go was
the two swords option okay so you gotta
hit the swords up top to challenge Mike
back and forth back and forth back and
forth
yeah they got seven seconds that's what
they're gonna make like three Queens and
then still meet you for sure okay it
didn't work all right
no no another car valiantly you want at
least one game today though game all
right you're on the board of Paris here
you go here we go
oh that's right we're all miked up so we
got to remember that okay oh so there's
a mic down there that you obably got to
put on if people want to hear you okay
I'm not doing here
no no technical guy Danny help yeah I
play this I play the Sicilian after you
you're my inspiration for this this line
and I want to play just like you so show
me how it's done
can you show me I mean I'm in a studio
right now doing a show so it'll be
different when I come back I'll be a lot
better right yeah oh oh no no you're
fine oh because every time you touch the
computer go do the function up
brightness there help there does 8989
know what is this dark horse is reading
with a party of seven no idea what that
means
absolutely no idea okay so really eighty
nine plus six right I don't know I don't
know what rating means what does it mean
here's some behind-the-scenes magic
though here's what it means
they were streaming and brought all
their viewers to you yes Thank You Dark
Horse didn't the Queens gambit declined
or goes in variation is worthy of its
own chess openings explained 100% yeah I
love that opening since you're getting
technical issues I've been giving you
some additional time Oh what did I
didn't you're nice opponent gave you
like 30 seconds back thank you don't you
playing my name is Joey what's his name
on here just cuz you gave him mercy
don't expect any in return now crush him
no you're fine big move you got this you
got this come on
all right good one Miko's know he wants
to checkmate you yeah do you also made
me hide my g5 who named you for there
stop stop don't mess with Perry when
he's in the middle of a game I don't
know if we can hear him but the man a
pawn what's up Giovanni's see you
tonight the quads I know I can't wait to
see audio brother of Grand Master Raksha
Chandra oh yeah
interesting back I am actually wearing
ox on Chandra uh 2015 US Junior
Championship thus the shirt data
Oxshott one is they view what the Chess
Club was a very victorious one Junior
Championship we always have mouse issues
we always get weird Mouse's we go
straight from Danny's super gamer mouse
to whatever basic most but this is
probably best for us that's the thing
field polo left just let me know it's
possible we have we have a lot finding
the size you need that's the real
challenge if you send an email go to
info at which reckon text in the chat we
can tell you if we got it
info
Louis just send an email if you're
interested in that that polo will let
you know forgot it way too fast
par for the course Queens effects oh my
god I see that why does he just got
played oh we can't play rook f7 our work
takes Paulin yeah and then we're taking
on d3 which for just two of his pieces
threatening checkmate and then he just
got f6 covered pretty well para there
one thing you're doing alright slightly
down time but gaining time is about to
be an issue he just needs to play work
takes pawn and don't play well you can
only do that once
alright take the other pond on take this
guy and now Queen to - II - there he is
- you made it - were closed here's
Dennis LaRue for you night check no
goodnight to g3 Jack hurry work the
Queen bucks who cares you might not see
it and the Queen check right away
well it's his only legal check right
away and just hope it's checkmate it's
not honey that's that's not each other
there's no delay I played 96 right away
there's no delay but there's a delay
look I'm watching it with a delay that's
not look I'm waving now and then we'd
audio yeah so it's easy to cheat good to
know
Oh check me oh yeah he's been looking
for a game okay good play it's not that
easy man now a good game buddy skill all
right we got checkmate 31 41 all right
all right let's win this thing are you
all done playing Mike no I'll be back
I'll be back after this game better than
ever
all right go get good do whatever you
gotta do 13:31 boys there are few and
far between
so this is slowly going up about 68
people here well we got to get to 101
rate us any more people raving us
minesweeper just to warm up that I
should be saying most Mike is a
professional minesweeper I would play
one game a minesweeper at expert level
on combat vets and that's not a joke
he's much better than he is at chess
if you can believe it somehow honey
what's your leach s handle if we see it
we'll play you who's gonna play Adi it
should be Dennis that'd be funny is to
me every funny us to me that's hanging a
bishop but it is I don't know
Knight takes bishop Oh Anne is hanging a
bishop yeah please choose me Danny
listen listen alright if you challenge
me to one oh you'll be next up when
Mike's back we'll get the big game with
Quinton Jonathan we still see the old
game on stream Oh Danny is there a tech
issue we still see old game on stream
you should be watching checkmates versus
us get quick sign this one resigned a
sign that change the screen don't let
anybody see what just happened is this
the senior section this young guy I
already said senior section yeah me
Coase getting you good let's meet you
out on a racquetball court Miko's
checkmate gloating lol they just got
killed
alright thank you for the game checkmate
thank you I might have to get in here
but let's make sure they can see it I
got it what oh do I have to uh my gosh I
have to unlike here and then remake
there okay so they see it now yeah
oh wait I got a unn mic and then remake
all right good game checkmate all right
guys Danny I can't I'm hopeless is that
true do we want lie chests notifications
oh no no we never resigned this feels
disrespectful
yeah our apologies all right all right
I'm here for my first my first here and
what if we got we got anybody good here
1,900 it's casual why are they all
casual come on all right we got a 1900
here let's let's play play Merlin the
wizard
good to see you Merlin but let me see
this cuz I don't want to look at the
chest I just want to talk to the chat
people and no we need this maybe I'll
get to paint him
who was talking about the rigo's in I
would have played it but they didn't
allow it they were talking about it I
think it's a great opening so I would
have played it oh they are casual
because we feel bad taking all your pom
take them off yeah I mean it's it hurts
but it's true all right
all right Jonathan one of yours were
three away from a hundred sit here and
boom okay so here's a line they don't
really know well and what do you do in
this one don't know an opening will say
it ain't so so you're Nate so I go here
hoping they don't do this cuz I mean
maybe I'll take this yeah I don't really
do any openings I was trying to play
there it goes in for our dear viewer
which I actually do know this yeah well
fake it this is usually a situation
where even if Lex down upon there's
always some compensation on the
queenside and stuff but here we go I get
to develop my stuff relatively quickly
and then when the good people play
you're always down upon but you have a
slight initiative and then you make some
easy drop because you're a professional
player um what's he hinting at he's
going here
let's just go here he might attack me no
well then do it
I do want to get my stuff out quickly I
don't know if it's worth wasting a time
to allow such thing ok so Michael there
I'll continue developing my stuff
expecting Bishop b2
somehow I should get this Queen right
there that's primo vit uh he went there
indeed already this guy actually might
be better off here if he takes I will
take with something probably my bun
don't believe me get some stuff going
here oh but it doesn't make an arrow is
that just the thing glitching shrine
arrow is that what it looks like on the
stream oh now it became an arrow Oh
doesn't show the cursors oh so if I draw
arrows people don't see it no I'm not
gonna say that the squares come on
no one could follow that doesn't show up
on there when I try us doing it what are
people supposed to do talk in chess
notation alright so that does make it a
little bit difficult for this guy to get
out and by this guy I mean the nighttime
be one you can say my what square I've
clicked on yeah I'd like to say things
like this one that piece and then you
never really mess up you know you don't
ever call a knight a bishop or something
alright no time for the typical plan if
I knew what that was we would do it well
your plan is to get your queen of G to
remember yeah he's gonna take my pawn
though
so f5 don't listen to me listen I trust
my cover wholeheartedly
I trust my cover wholeheartedly so now
when my Queen moves away there's gonna
be this sort of check and you know well
you have Queen up see this or a check I
mean Queen g5 I need to know yes ooh
Queen f6 93 rook takes pawn rook takes
oh you can get rid of that
oh it may be preparing rook a3 here
that's fine
like we don't go into B - okay so shucks
oh wait a minute we still have the rook
takes point idea now rook takes pawn
and that's what your home before hoping
for some sort of initiative your our
down upon but that's fine that's a place
opening now things all right sort of
like my position the ASA plays like live
I can't I don't see what you should plan
I know in case he hears me didn't you
were trying to cheat against us
I'm barely watching this dream I'm a
loser
now what yeah we're super winning on
time though that's that's crucial here
I'm gonna try keep playing those Mike
would never play see if I can find one I
don't know let's get them my other rook
in love it that's about time I would
have just let them have my Bishop on eat
get in there this is funny cuz it's like
double protected kind of sure okay but
now for some deep accurate moves here
deep accurate rook takes rook yeah way
to really think about Oh work takes book
Oh what about Queen de Miranda move all
right great just don't don't get
checkmated I'll try not to have no
promises alright Kings pretty safe on
that diagonal clean up six ultra
protection that's why suicide yes go
fight for sale mate I like all right I
did it won a game of chess finally are
you ready to get back in yeah we're up
to 112 all right well it's time for Mike
then right I don't want to steal your
show I don't know if that's even true of
course they do
what have they been saying this the
problem is I can't look at the chat the
whole time and obsessively listen to
whatever they're saying while I'm
playing chess which is more important to
me than the chess we ready for someone
oh right I remember you were gonna play
Quintin help this challenge is not up
there all three old standard but maybe
that's what I need maybe that's what I
need what happened to my position a
casual casual Quintus key wants to play
me five oh really did Audis name is Adi
Adi
but he's casual we play for keeps
we play for a change it Mike spec 5o is
just a little too long twenty aren't all
trying to play the fried liver against
Mike please please bring two fried liver
back into my life
let's go he might be 1051 they don't
even know I like the ideas when they
don't even know what the rating is I
tried so hard to get on the stream Adi
he's never beat me in his life he always
gets a huge advantage and then just
blunders away all his pieces so I always
wished that Adi Chandra was the number
two chess player in the whole world that
way I would be the world champion of all
time and everybody would be like wow how
good is this guy Denis is on the case
hey Ron I'm playing a DJ Chandra so I
better win all right that's the voice of
Ryan Chester who'll be here on Wednesday
all right Wednesday stream coming up
with Ryan Chester that's the most
exciting strand the host of between
through palms yeah that's Mike very
exciting
no tink why don't you take out c7o I'm
setting up I'm setting up something more
devious now it's so much better double
check you could have had one check but
now you got double check lot to learn
from you all right be greedy it be
greedy yeah I want to see people play
the fried liver and get crushed by Mike
yeah yeah of course he floated you see
where am i knocking yeah when there's a
night their music took a rook you know
what daddy just for you Castle that's
what a book told me it's three for two
and now I got a bunch of past Paul and
we'll need to decide who's playing for
Mike when Mike steps out the senior are
you guys watching this upstairs I'm good
Kylie's watching me good oh oh yeah yeah
Kylie and it's out all my jokes on my
opr articles Kyle Mike wrote this this
excellent NPR piece and Kylie was just
in new and chess so if you want to see
Kylie you can look her up she's in the
new and chess magazine that we her not
taught to write no to a very famous
photo oh oh wow and then oh he's got a
big like I can't a toast is willing to
play the Friday over against Mike his
ideas Chad s but unfortunately that
sounds like Mike is gonna have to
disappear
just for a minute one minute that's good
I'll have to get Perry in because I got
it so hard taking a mic off putting a
mic on hey hello nirvana it's good to
see you again
okay 3:45 all head out of here alright
so I'm here for like 20 more minutes
comer will be back until then what Barry
I think I shot just took over this Ryan
are you gonna make a physical appearance
on the stream so they know how to look
forward to on Wednesday it'll be a
surprise all right
oh yeah double Fork Hank don't get four
you know
yeah I guess I oughta has not watched it
works every time Ryan's around if you
haven't watched Perry's episode of don't
get forked
you haven't lived life a hundred exactly
under exactly are watching sure got you
started off slow today for some reason
but uh yeah we're up 200 worry about me
okay just don't worry about me don't
worry about me
check oh [ __ ] there was nothing SEC I
wanted Oh
with what Oh in almost checkmate yes
all right well done Mike you got you
right time to roll all right hi I'm new
to this channel and half of the viewers
don't it's the senior section tasty
waffle no rematch sorry Ani yeah we can
I can't rematch we got enough people
good it's a closed set now that's good
sounds like there's a lot of important
business going on out there okay so
y'all make that one we got you got the
mic on yep can you hear me I don't know
if I can hear all right I hope so cause
I got a mic tub I'm gonna get ten
challenges so yes
all right 1760 rated all right let's do
this
all right all right concentrate all
right well senior section barely know
the rules
yeah that's the name I've seen he said
he barely knows the rules
yeah I barely know the rules 1760 rating
a user name I barely know the room I
complain I'm on one of the streams
assuming it's a him
but all right I would take the advice of
my partner general insurance and try to
develop my pieces not blood or anything
that's why I'm gonna try to do I'll talk
a good start we're gonna try choose me I
know
Clinton Mike was meant to play you but I
guess the stars have not aligned develop
my pieces haven't blundered anything yet
so all right there you go all right no
wonder your stuff he's gonna trying to
fianchetto was a white squared bishop oh
my goodness yeah maybe we'll get the
rematch with I barely know the rules I
think comer stink and I'm not messing
around
HS you win all the time yeah I don't
even know how to play it digest me
there's no way you're supposed to lose I
think is that the one with pieces blow
up and that's one we're supposed to try
the worst move instead of the best move
yeah not up on all of the cool variants
okay so that's a weak piece right there
then your bishop should be on e6 it
should be it should be right one again I
want to play with Dennis yeah we gotta
get Dennis on the stream regularly so if
I play here you can attack my knight and
then I got an escape square right here
so I think Wednesday is sort of looking
like it'll be the sort of the
miscellaneous player day it's been a
busy week here that's why I Mike is out
destroy your scholastic players and
teachers like good one bit see what
Dennis is awesome otherwise he's got
this little thing at which frame ah what
are you doing to me dude I sent a rated
300 challenge my name same as here sir
Nicks
so if you want to please their necks
next it's in the queue
hanging anything
have you been playing racquetball
recently I have I have
I've played like four times in the last
weekend have to be honest yes I'm
playing a lot I'll just take this guy
we'll just move away we don't want to
get on this to challenge me Dennis left
the room with Mike left is it is very
nice that you're reading chat lots of
chess channels I have to have too many
replies and don't bother
yeah it's we got a nice little number
here we're up to 113 watching so it's
not going too fast and we have extra
people here just to read the chat that's
my job it's a it's a good job too
playing chess that's too hard
alright the legend is back Anthony's
tons of people are in the queue
everybody might cover they all want my
cover so we'll get Mike what do we got
here you attack his queen's cheytac his
queen whatever you do I think I would
check his queen do it then
alright yep his business way bigger than
your Bishop though not for long can you
checkmate me here okay
all right so just go on till I shut the
door if they're gonna be loud out there
I want my comer me too
that's what I look forward to on Fridays
no Fridays at 2:30 Central Time that's
what I'm that's what I wait for it I
wake up on Friday waiting for my comer I
barely want so this I barely know the
rules guy I think that's is that Nirvana
man you know you played that I barely
knows the rules who's really like at
2300 or something okay yeah yeah if they
might want to rematch
yeah well we'll see what who's in the
queue and that's a good one cuz if you
lose no no blame I cover if you win your
glorious hero for all time Oh Jonathan
you didn't say close close the door it's
a scary world outside ah someone's been
watching my videos but this isn't the
classroom there is a woozle in the
kingside classroom I think the studio is
pretty safe we are under kingside though
so it is technically kingside and that
many people know this we can actually
get into kingside from this I know we
got this we do have a secret escape
tunnel here straight the Kings side if
need be well yeah I don't spend much
time in the classroom anymore so I
haven't heard the woozle in a while the
whistles probably before Perry's time
tell Dennis to challenge me Adi you can
just come to the Chess Club in real life
does it get to the drinks yeah we got
the the bar right behind us we can sneak
around Kings side when they're not
looking
King sides actually opening up another
establishment really move let's go it's
gonna be two Kings side soon 9.3 just
free move Knight f3 watch time they say
they say what's your time just yeah just
random and I know three was way cooler
snowing come in again quick faster any
square back and now go without three no
alright alright you're gonna win on time
if you just pre move look might do
something how do we know we expect to
see you at the quads super double
confirmed he just lost oh no tell who's
my queen Knight takes let's go alright
yeah just a fast they got eight seconds
I can't do it now they're gonna check
you supreme over King move after that
yeah alright drop it somebody move
anyone yeah if you throw on a knight
check just for fun now quick fast
illegal move oh damn it alright too much
all right well thank you Perry you
played all right I got I got weird one
that time came into the consideration
just a meeting yeah that was a quick the
quickest meeting I've ever seen around
here I get to the point I'd like answer
their questions and get on with the show
no we're not doing that no that's why
I'm not invited them
don't play me all right Honda Accord you
might be 1393 nobody knows nobody knows
all right what's happening Honda Accord
oh we played Honda Accord once good
let's feed them again beat them again
okay well we beat them we've already
played this yeah I do yep yep you're
done for Street has one chance he had
one chance he needs to beat you come
here in real life Adi just play the guy
in real life he's going the ice castle
in the other way that's not fun that's
never fun you Castle that way I'll
Castle that way okay this bring real
challenge I don't see any challenges
from here but Mike might sir Knicks
we're gonna get in Quinton is still
probably in the Quinton point it I gave
you your chance I said hey challenge me
one Oh BIP see what since I've never
beaten Mike comer in real life frowny
face I wonder who bitsy is yeah who are
you that's like are your people I mean I
assume we know these people there's tons
of people we know watching which is
pretty cool yep I'm gonna win this one
I'm gonna win this one ro and eight
moves gotta do better now yeah take it
he's is enough Florida right now Evan
Kelly I have beaten my comer who's that
who's Rick TV no idea who this is but
he's on turbo he's got a little turbo
symbol next to his name whatever that
means I never beat my comer either but
then again I've never played my comer
yeah
you don't play Mike you don't beat Mike
sometimes playing Mike doesn't mean that
you beat Mike either
nobody gotta win this mic you gotta go
fast go fast not slow fast not slow my
name is Eric here's a hint a lot of
Eric's come through here
that's Eric with Kay Eric tink chenko I
didn't want to say his name alone in the
case
Oh oh my god draw embarrassing
embarrassing yeah well at least I got on
the scoreboard that time I barely know
the rules thank God thank God thank I
got an idea he can't even move the so
this this guy I think is like a bullet
superstar cuz I think the other ratings
are not as I remember my name is Joey
says my name is Joey but I think you may
have guessed that on your own yeah but
you never know it's like the flagger
yeah egg the flag
you got this don't be nervous you're
good
yeah my Brooke I don't care I don't care
hello because Baku's isn't that who we
like because we know probably everybody
is like people we know we know I like
everybody it's 115 people watching and
we know them all they're all like club
members oh I just lost that guy that
barely knows the world
yeah and use like 15 seconds always late
to the stream yeah we're gonna get sort
of a regular schedule going because so
it'll be to 30s on Friday I'll be
Tuesdays at like noon Ryan will be
Wednesdays at sometime GM's will be
Thursdays at sometime still figuring it
out we're getting the whole schedule
thank you for the game I barely know the
rules okay
aimin man he got with the program he got
with the program Ryan at Wednesday at
3:00 the grandmaster at 3:00 on
Thursdays is what I'm being told and
that's all Central Time here in st.
Louis
oh what's going on not messing around
anymore I'm not messing around this is
what we're here to see right I can't
believe this one for him to show up see
you at the Chess Club Mike Perry
Jonathan all right we'll see you Artie
sounds like he's leaving we should see
him in about five minutes all right good
game I barely know the rules
my name is Joey says I'm not but I wish
I did if I ever get to st. Louis I'll
definitely want to see the Chess Club we
hope to see you here yeah yeah everyone
should check it out see the studio
you had a fork on queen and king LOL
yeah pretty funny stuff pretty funny
stuff eight more times that's that's
nirvan who I think is I barely know the
rules there this is this is how you play
chess this is how this is how your guns
the double check who goes the double
check yeah that's how you play chess
that's how you play chess so Eric
last name already given out saying can
you come stream in the studio
most people I'd say no for Eric ah
kramnik student good oh good good good I
need my rematch again cranek student
barely beat he beat me on time last
crushing crannis yeah no problem Eric
Eric's been around long enough I say
Eric wants the stream looking brakeman
well game yeah he's been around give him
a trial very long time yeah you're in
Florida I know quite a lot of people in
Florida I played a tournament in Florida
once just won your land Oh autumn open
parallel or in st. Louis get out here
and me Perry and Orion went down to
Florida Key West to a directed chess
tournament this year or last year last
September and it was a lot of fun
floating in the ocean floating in the
ocean
keep it to the 100 challenges yeah
that's what we're doing that's what we
do and wait are you saying that to the
people or yeah yeah oh yeah Kramnik
student was asking you yeah we're just
101 Oh rated rated yeah he's gonna take
a sweet time but he'll challenge you
eventually well we might only be only
going on for another 20 minutes right so
yeah is that true really knows the rules
is USCF rated yeah we got 120 more
minutes of this rated so that's that
light so like yeah get your games in
while you can
five more games yeah I'm sure rain I'll
call me out in like five minutes
you might be all alone all alone oh God
everybody wants me to take this pawn so
I will oblige I will oblige give him a
Chuck
I am the favorite in this but you never
know huh you never know
yeah hard to get a USCF rating if you
don't go to the US there Joe I'm walking
into checkmate walking into checkmate
walking into checkmate easy win easy
flagging operation all right that's two
in a row by Mike al with the 500 bits
oh there's Quentin all right all right
Quentin you want it you got it Quentin
all right I'm toned in now I'm so many
so much because what is USCF rating it's
the United States Chess Federation so if
you play in the US most tournaments will
be USCF rated
if I move alright alright deal
this is almost too easy hello alexandria
from Quebec
yeah everybody saw it everybody saw it
your tricks don't work on me
hey tricks just don't work on me
oh you trick still don't work on how
this guy photos thank you very much
ideal dude this is like my most crushing
defeat of the day this is good my got it
back a slow start
it was a slow start but no it's
definitely coming together that we're
singing yeah just give up Yeah right
thank you thank you thank you all right
I might get up to 1,800 that's my goal
eight hundred and seventeen minutes okay
I barely know the rules is taunting you
my tricks worked on you lol yeah
lonely munchies he doesn't know what is
raiding is so it's like kind of play
more games to get a real ring I mean
didn't got crushed yeah thank you for
the game Quinton
hello from Newberg giovanna's let's
trade everything on f4 hear you now
everybody watching is a member of the
chess club hello that's good broaden our
base
broaden your base they are actually
watching that's good
oh it's not very nice you know what
yeah be afraid be afraid promising for
you my attacks better than your attack
it opened up the G file open dunno many
are from chess 24 ya chemic student I
have seen you on young Gustafson
streaming assuming you're the same guy
[Music]
wide open it's what all he has to do is
move that night and I got checked me
okay that's not even true yeah just give
up I'm too good I'm too good you don't
know what to do you don't know what to
do fine you don't want Trey Queens there
are trade Queens there that's fine with
me however you want to trade Queens
however you want to do it it's kind of
scary actually check you got your speed
back and that's important element here
another chick Oh as a bad check take
take that and now Chuck some random
checks victoriously I got 12 points for
that and I and I put him down to size
two it barely knows the rules
Oh blindfold ability well--we're oh oh
once I said his name guess what
challenge just went away
oh he'll exceed take like he's like a
challenge comb or blindfold ability now
once I say a about ready to accept you
like just take it away
oh you soft 2009 hopefully it's the one
you saw I know I think I can beat this
kid I think I think so here was born in
2009 that means so I'm playing like a 8
year old or 10
year old maybe just turned ten birthday
you saw thousands anymore I miss
watching your openings explains meet me
too now I'm just getting into the big
twitch streaming world yeah but I get
the good job mostly most days I just sit
here reading your chat cuz I'd rather
talk to you my name is Joey that and the
real story as I had a baby Jim
McLoughlin took my job everybody's happy
oh yeah hopefully I'll be present on
YouTube in the future
justtake it should be good I always get
up well okay
don't predict what in 1160 s gonna do
Chuck looks good
just take everything take everything
blindfold Billie's that's Eric Hey right
I was gonna blindfold them he
accidentally made it unrated so he was
trying to switch it to rate in fear oh
yeah yeah yeah he's got all the excuses
all right he's got forget it I'm not
playing them anymore
he had his chance telling me he had his
chance checkmate the old fashioned way
checkmate ha ha ha oh I thought I had
checkmate maybe I need to take that job
because I was too busy so Oh double
check some random rook move anywhere
there's a great video of them on
Hamilton losing his mind because he
couldn't make pre moves against 11
hundreds huh yeah Eric you got scammed
yeah there's the number 5 crazy house
player inline chess and we probably have
somebody on staff that plays variants
imagine some point people will probably
stream some variants for everybody
inclined I might actually lose this game
when Yasir is here just in the nick of
time huh like a victorious they really
got that good now Mike's on fire so he's
unbeatable
the street oh no I got one point for
that okay so I got I need 19 points and
11 minutes here kramnik student alright
alright Oh control 100 rated
that's what he plays Mike is in great
form that's and then quick your opponent
in this game let's give you credit
yeah just giving a coin out of there
always sees all the tricks he sees all
the tricks I do already I barely yeah
one once yeah you get your chance and
then get on with your life okay
crush Mike once in the leaf I don't know
what's going on here I don't yeah play
chess you can challenge us st. Louis
club
it's crushing me on time and in the
position no my gosh this guy got me he
got me good he got me good
all right just draw you back and forth
back and forth back what's up guy in a
box
yes was just guy in box what's the trick
not anymore not anymore hey I only
didn't oh yes that's what we do today
guy in box with the boxes symbols oh
what a way to beat me huh a little way
to beat me he's pretty good he's pretty
good he pretty gay you got a good lesson
today well Honda Accord I kind of like I
kind of like playing you said no to
blindfold Billy shut that down look teen
man 25 let's get straight A's too good
he's to you and he's too good
Eric you had your chance you had your
chance didn't beat in in for Mike yeah
you took him down he was on high like I
got the color variation the Karma
variation people 25
well let's see yeah let's see if you can
find a meeting yeah that's good enough
to be world champion right what was that
what did he miss a mate in twenty six or
something and that good enough to be
world champion though not good enough 25
by comparison a relatively easy task
all right I'm getting the big call here
from the big boss oh that means it's my
time to leave we got eight minutes tell
them we got eight minutes that tell him
you'll be there in eight minutes
it's question mark it's Queen yeah all
right all right I should win this one
but just cuz I should doesn't mean I
will
especially what moves like that yeah we
got to get this cleaned out of here yeah
all right he's still talking about it
who's getting high praise from everyone
in the chat to beat my comer is a is a
truly amazing task gosh darn we need oh
I likes Andrea just challenge us one Oh
give it a try come on come on come on
like so fast like so fast like so fast I
knew you both from YouTube before twitch
yes oh draw timeout timeout whipped with
zero seconds left he can make it you can
make it that's how good he he doesn't
even need time he doesn't even need time
there you go that might be it that might
be it that's a high note right I drew
them with zero seconds I think that's it
Jonathan's gotta go I gotta go
that's a high note for me sweet all
right so yeah our next stream will be on
Tuesday
I guess at noon it'll be me I'll be
playing something like 5 minute or some
other time control I want to thank
everyone in chat 1 was just great again
obviously lots of people we know lots of
new people and obviously thanks to Mike
comer for being here the next time I'll
start I'll drink faster and better and I
get it I get get in the zone early and
often all right thanks everybody see
next article e Danny knows how to shut
this